I've got a fantastic book recommendation
for you today
the book is cosmos by Carl Sagan now you
might be saying David that book is more
than 35 years old at this point why are
you only now reading it and yes I've
never got around to reading cosmos by
Carl Sagan I finally have there's a new
edition with a great introduction by
Neil deGrasse Tyson who has the story of
having written a letter to Carl Sagan
when he was teaching at Ithaca College
in Ithaca New York and being invited
what was a typical college or was at
Cornell anyway they're both in it the
kind of New York but a spare spare me
the criticism of that one detail if I
got it wrong and Carl Sagan invited Neil
deGrasse Tyson to go and to spend some
time with him there and we know what
that did for Neil deGrasse Tyson's
career the book is fantastic and it
really gives you it's sort of like an
overview of the past present and future
of science through space exploration and
the history of the universe and there's
so much good writing in there to help
you understand the scope of the universe
both in terms of time and size is this a
book you've read before Pat it is not
but from my understanding people like
Carl Sagan and Neil deGrasse Tyson
obviously incredibly intelligent but
also have this ability to relay their
information and what they know in a
format that people understand to
understand who may not follow this sort
of thing that's the key thing when you
read through this book and I encourage
you to do it you actually understand in
a way that makes sense to laypeople who
aren't necessarily in the fields of
different fields of science the concepts
that are being discussed Einstein's
special theory of relativity the size of
the universe be the passing of time and
all of these different things are
explained in ways that really resonate
with just the average person so I
recommend you read the book cosmos by
Carl Sagan you can check out all of my
recommendations by going to david
pakman.com slash recommendations
importantly I don't really care where
you get these books or recommendations
as long as you get them I think they're
really good but if you want to help
support the work we do if you go to
david pakman.com slash recommendations
any of the links there
for streaming buying books whatever
Kindle etc if you use those links we get
a little kickback for everything you buy
or stream or read so please consider
that david pakman.com slash
recommendations we will take a break
we've got a great program for you today
follow me on twitter i'm on twitter at D
Pakman